well since it's Friday I thought that it
could be fun to reach into the mailbag
not a literal mailbag I wish I wish I
had just had a bag of mail with
envelopes that I could reach into but a
metaphorical mailbag and tackle a
subject that was suggested to me via
email and by the way I always enjoy
these kinds of emails so anytime there's
a topic that you'd like me to hear me
babble about and I haven't battled about
before you can always suggest it it also
does my job for me by providing me with
content so I really appreciate that as
well alright so here is the the email it
says hi Matt first of all huge fan
I'm going because of my incredible
humility I will skip the first paragraph
that complements me and I'll go to the
next one as a 23 year old Christian girl
getting married and starting a family of
my own is something I'm really looking
forward to in life however recently I've
heard and read so many things about how
it's unnatural for men to be monogamous
I even watched a Netflix documentary
about why monogamy is not meant for
humans specifically men I'd like to say
that these studies don't bother me but
I'd be lying like most Millennials my
biggest fear is a failed marriage and
this is just fuel to the fire
anyway I would love to hear your take on
this matter so monogamy is unnatural is
the subject this obviously is
is an increasingly popular idea and it's
something that you know rather
frequently you'll see passed around on
social media you'll see an article being
passed around claiming that monogamy is
unnatural that monogamous relationships
are doomed to failure that being
polyamorous is is the more enlightened
choice in fact I saw an article on
Facebook recently that I guess was
related to a new show on the BBC about a
couple who are seeking to save their
marriage by having an open relationship
that is by cheating on each other
consensually and the articles promoting
the idea of having an open relationship
so I think the attack on monogamy is
often direct you have people directly
saying that monogamy is unnatural
implausible not feasible but then you
say you have that kind of attack but
then I think you have the more common
sort of attack on monogamy that is
implicit and sort of just cultural and
environmental
where people in my generation have grown
up in an environment where
that is just hostile to monogamy and and
where where if you didn't know any
better and you looked around you may
reach the ink the conclusion that
monogamy is somehow an impossibility
there there are a lot of people my
generation who were growing up as kids
they really never encountered a faithful
healthy monogamous relationship their
own parents were divorced their friend's
parents were divorced it's just divorce
all over the place
and so that's how a lot of people were
raised and it's no surprise that a lot
of them now as adults have decided that
you know marriage a healthy stable
marriage is impossible so there's no
reason to even try
now
I think there are a few different
aspects of this discussion that need to
be tackled or a few different questions
that need to be answered
number one is monogamy actually
unnatural number two is something like
an open marriage more natural or even
possible logically and number three is
monogamy possible so I'll try to tackle
these one at a time
number one is monogamy unnatural I think
the short answer is yes
and know
it depends on what you mean by natural
and thus what you mean by unnatural
now I think and and the way we talk
about things being natural it's very
convoluted and confused and people set
seem to be very inconsistent in in you
know in the times when they'll use this
idea of something being natural as a
justification for doing it like we're
very selective about that and I think
part of the confusion is that is that
the word natural as it pertains to
humans can mean one of two things so
when we say natural we could mean it in
the lower sense that is it's natural
because it's what we instinctively crave
it's natural because it satisfies some
base urge that we have you know so in
that way being polyamorous or sleeping
around being unfaithful that is a
natural thing in that sense it's natural
like like lying is natural like jealousy
is natural like hatred and gossip and
pride are all natural they're natural
like it's natural to get angry and punch
a wall
they're natural in the sense that you
could experience that urge and if you
have no discipline or self-control you
could easily slip into that
so that's what I mean by natural
a person who doesn't try to control
themselves and just lets themselves sort
of be that's how they're gonna be
they're gonna be they're gonna be you
know gossiping prideful lying unfaithful
they're gonna be all those things and in
that sense monogamy is unnatural in the
same way that it's unnatural to suppress
your anger or to exercise humility or to
refrain from lying and to tell the truth
even when the truth is painful or
inconvenient or uncomfortable so I think
natural in this sense in the sense that
being non-monogamous is natural would be
better called maybe bass or or even
animalistic
animalistic because animals are going to
experience a compulsion or an instinct
and then that's just how they're going
to act they're not going to choose to do
something else an animal is never going
to say well I really have the urge to do
this but I think that's wrong so I'm
going to do this instead animals will
never do that
and so a person who who says well I
can't be monogamous because it's not
natural what they're saying is basically
they don't want to live like a human
they don't they don't aspire to be a
human being they want it and they want
to be they want to live like a dog like
an animal but then there is natural in
the other sense I think the higher sense
the sense that maybe we would even call
supernatural and not supernatural
because it's magical but because it is
above instinct it is above compulsion it
is above urge
act this way we are we are separating
ourselves from nature to an extent we're
standing above nature in a way because
we are acting in a way that the rest of
nature is not capable of acting we are
making a choice that the rest of nature
animals and plants cannot make monogamy
lifelong devotion belongs to this
category and I know that there are some
examples in the animal kingdom of
monogamy that is animals who have a
lifelong partner but again that's very
different that's that's that's instinct
it's not like they have made this
promise in this commitment to each other
that I'm gonna stick by this person for
their this other creature for the rest
of my life that's that's not what's
going on
only humans can make that calculation
and make that choice so it's a higher
thing it's a greater more beautiful more
enriching thing but like all higher
things like all greater things that
requires effort and work and sacrifice
and discipline fidelity goes against our
baser urges
but not because it perverts those urges
or those instincts so it's not like it's
not like someone who hurts themselves on
purpose someone's that someone who's a
self-mutilator and so they they go
against the instinct for
self-preservation and the instinct to
avoid pain but in that case they go
against it in that they pervert it it's
not like that
monogamy fidelity it goes against our
instincts by reaching for something
beyond instant
and in that way I would argue that it is
the most natural the most human because
it's our ability to reach beyond
instinct and to act according to a
higher standard that makes us human
so in pursuing this path we really
become
our selves it's it you know by just
having sex with random people living a
life of selfishness
you're losing your human identity
and becoming this small and pathetic
little thing I don't want to get off on
a side on a you know I don't I get
sidetracked here but this is also why I
find the argument against free will so
completely stupid
I mean it's the stupidest argument that
you'll hear that even very smart people
will make trying to deny free will I
mean what are you talking about
it is obviously evident that we all have
free will because here's how I can prove
it okay I can really really really want
to do one thing and not do that thing
that's free will
no other n on the animal kingdom has
that we are the only ones who can do
that in the known universe were the only
ones we could really have an urge to do
something and yet do the the opposite
so I think when people who argue against
free will what they're really set
revealing about themselves is that they
are total absolute cowards and wimps and
that they in their own lives have never
actually resisted an urge have never
exercised any self-restraint and have
therefore decided that it's impossible
for everyone but it's not impossible it
is possible to do the fact that you
haven't done it just means that you're
weak but it can be done it can many
billions of people do it all the time so
that's you know that that's the
distinction between natural and
unnatural and I think you can see this I
mean talk to
talk to a couple that's been married for
50 or 60 or 70 years I think often what
you'll find when you talk to some people
like that is that they you know it's
like they've reached a higher mode of
existence you know you'll find a certain
piece a certain wisdom that's grown from
a life of love and devotion and you can
contrast that with someone who's older
and is gone you know is also older like
like them like the old married couple
but let's take someone who's who's older
and and has gone from marriage to
marriage
lived a life of self-seeking of self
involvement never managed to have really
a healthy faithful relationship and what
you'll notice about that kind of person
is that they've kind of caved in on
themselves and they become like shells
and all it was real and vital and
awesomely human about them has been
eaten away
and that is what being natural has
gotten number two these days we have the
idea of an open relationship or an open
marriage and this seems to me to be a
contradiction in terms you know saying
open marriage is like saying dry lake or
something now a lake might dry out you
know of course but but once it has dried
out it's not a lake anymore so no such
thing as a dry lake it's not a lake it's
just a big hole in the ground
and I think something similar is the
case with an open marriage now of course
it's hard to make this case in modern
times when people don't recognize that
marriage has any particular definition
or purpose and if marriage is just
literally any kind of arrangement if
it's just whatever you want it to be
then marriage is nothing it means
nothing by opening up the definition of
something and including all definitions
within it you haven't gained a new
definition you have just lost definition
that was the whole argument about that
was the argument that these supporters
of so-called traditional marriage have
always made is it's an argument of
definite it's an argument of logic
saying look marriage is a certain thing
serves a certain purpose
if you erase those lines and say well
it's not that thing anymore it doesn't
serve that purpose anymore then you have
to come up with a new definition
that can still exclude all other
definitions because if it's not a
definition that excludes other
definitions then it's not a definition
the problem is that the people who
who have advocated for this new
definition of marriage they never
actually came up with a new definition
the old definition is very simple very
straightforward the marriage is a is a
lifelong commitment between a man and a
woman that is a life long fruitful
commitment between a man and woman that
serves as the foundation for a family
that's what a you know it's what a
marriage
now you could disagree with that but at
least it is a thing it make you know
what that is it has definition it has
purpose it has function okay
if you're coming in and saying well it
doesn't need to be lifelong doesn't need
to be monogamous doesn't need to be
fruitful doesn't need to serve as a
foundation of a family well then what is
it what in the world is this thing now
it just went from a thing that is is a
thing to a thing that's nothing unless
you can come up with some new depth but
no one bothered to do that and so now we
just all we've done is literally gotten
rid of marriage at least in the in our
in a from a cultural standpoint and from
a legal standpoint
but the fact still remains even if we
don't recognize it as a culture if we
don't recognize legally marriage is
still marriage
between a man and a woman and that part
is important because one of the primary
functions are said of a marriage is to
serve as the basis for the family and
only a man and woman can biologically
create a family and the lifelong a
monogamous part is important because
that is why a family requires in order
to be stable happy and healthy now you
might say what about polygamy which
obviously has plenty of historical
precedent well I I think polygamy is a
primitive kind of arrangement that we
have grown past I think also that
polygamy could have arguably been
necessary in the earlier days the very
early days of human civilization when
human beings had to do quite a lot of
reproducing in order to reach stable
population numbers but that's not the
case anymore
and anyway polygamy in the traditional
sense is not the same as this modern
idea of an open marriage where spouse
goes out and has sex with whoever they
want just for fun for recreation and
then comes home and to their to their
spouse and pretends that they love them
and it also isn't the same as the modern
system of marrying and divorcing a whole
string of people so at the end of your
life you have a you know at the end of
your life you can look back and see that
you have four or five spouses but you
just had them in succession instead of
all at once I think even the polygamists
of old would would have found both of
those arrangements to be absurd and
horrifying
so but you know open marriage is is it's
it's a you know it's a dry lake it's a
it's a square circle it's a contradict
and contradiction in terms the thing
that makes if a marriage is a marriage
if it means anything one of the central
things that make it a marriage is that
it is closed
that it is a bond between two people men
and women closed off from others is a
unique and special bond 3 is monogamy
possible is it possible or feasible to
get married and stay married and remain
faithful to one person for your whole
life and for that let me let me offer an
emphatic yes
and this is one of the most frustrating
thing to things to me that that people
who have failed in their relationships
and failed in their marriages will very
often argue that essentially their
experiences is universal you know nobody
can be sure in their marriage nobody can
rule out divorce at that's sort of what
they'll say that's the message that
newlyweds and people who are you know
discerning marriage that's the message
that they hear and they'll hear that
well if you're happily married right now
or if you're about to get married
watch out because it could happen to you
at any time the divorce could just
happen to you
the end of your marriage could just
happen but you could just trip into it
like a puddle write your vows your
promises your plans all that really
doesn't mean anything but it's nice but
it doesn't mean anything
this is the attitude that people seem
seem to want young married couples to
have and I find it detestable honestly
I find it to test Monday
talk about this publicly about the issue
of divorce and you know being faithful
to your spouse and so on
um or I've talked about myself I've said
you know been married for seven years
I'm never gonna divorce my wife III have
had in so many cases I've been told by
people who have been divorced and
they've said they said well pride comes
before the fall what kind of thing is
that to say some you're saying it's
prideful that I'm not gonna divorce my
wife I'm arrogant for that because I
made a vow and I planned to stick with
it that makes me arrogant and prideful
what a horrible awful thing that do you
realize how horrible that is to say to
people
I mean you may as well you may as well
just wish to you might as well tell them
you're gonna get I hope you get divorced
one day it's what you're doing I and I
really think that's the case I think
there are a lot of people who have you
know experienced a lot of misery in
their life in their lives much of it
self-inflicted and they really do wish
it on others they want other people to
experience
let me let me say this that's all bull
and if you're if you're getting married
or if you're a young married couple
don't listen to it don't listen to these
miserable people who would try to foist
their miseries on you don't listen
people who say you know I couldn't do
this so nobody can don't listen to them
here's an absolute fact about marriage
if both of you are 100% committed to it
and you remain committed to it and above
all you remain totally faithful to one
another your marriage will last as long
as you live
guaranteed all you have to do is fulfill
those two things if both of you do
you're committed faithful your marriage
lasts I mean it's really as simple as
that
it's impossible that you could both do
that and and complete that task on a
daily base a if you're doing that every
day you're not going to trip and fall
and end up divorced one day
and is any of that impossible or
unrealistic is it impossible or
unrealistic to be committed and faithful
no it's not only possible but it's
completely feasible it's not only
feasible but it's even easy
easy when you look at it objectively I
mean easy when you look at it this way
okay look look at this way you say to
yourself I'm married okay
I can be faithful and committed or not
and then and then you you think so this
is just you're being objective right
two paths like faithful committed paths
and then the unfaithful non-committal
path
and then you think about where each path
will take you
the faithful and committed path is not
only morally correct but it's also way
way easier
I mean it's difficult in the sense that
it requires sacrifice honesty work and
so on but it's easy in that it's much
simpler it's much more peaceful much
happier and you avoid all the
complications and dramas and deceits
that mark the lives of unfaithful and
uncommitted people
um you know in a sense in a similar
sense you could say it's it's much
easier to eat healthy and get exercise
and live a healthy life it's easier now
little sacrifices are required to
maintain such a life and in the moment
like when you are choosing to have
broccoli and you compare that to the
choice to eat ice cream seems like a
harder choice and when you're going for
a jog and you compare that to the choice
of sitting on the couch the jog seems
like the harder choice
but if you look at it in its totality
objectively you see that the other
option to be a lazy glutton who eats ice
cream all the time and just sitting lays
around on the couch that will lead to
huge complications down the road all
kinds of health problems and ultimately
to the biggest sacrifice of all your
life you're gonna die it will kill you
of course we're all gonna die but that
lifestyle will kill you much sooner so
in that sense
to eat healthy and to get exercise see
it really is easier it makes your life a
lot easier
there's a great line at the end of
Graham Greene's book power and the glory
I think I mentioned before one of my
favorite books and there's a line that
it's a scene where a priest is in jail
he's awaiting execution martyrdom and
though this priest has done a heroic
thing by in the end sticking to his
faith even when faced with death up
until that point he had lived a sinful
life he was a drunk he had an
illegitimate child okay and so as he was
in his cell awaiting execution Green has
this line to describe his state of mind
the line is it seemed to him at that
moment that it would have been quite
easy to have been a saint it would only
have needed a little self-restraint and
a little courage and I've always thought
always loved that line
and that whole scene because of how
deeply true it seems
and you can really imagine yourself in a
cell awaiting execution and having the
exact same thought
that really to be a saint to be a good
person is actually really easy when you
look at it objectively all it requires
in any given situation most of the time
is a little bit of self-restraint a
little bit of courage a little bit of
selflessness 99% of the moments in our
lives only require the smallest little
smidgen of saintliness
99% of time that is all that's required
so that to be a bad person to live a bad
life
it means that you have to consistently
refuse even in the pettiest situations
you have to refuse to even be a little
bit selfless selfless and a little bit
honest and you have to consistently make
that refusal
where you see after a while it's almost
like it requires more effort to be a bad
person
because you have to do it be so
consistently bad at a certain point you
think you just give up on it and say
fine I'll just be a good prayer it's so
much easier to just be a good person and
I think a similar similar thing is the
case with marriage marriage is most
often fail because one or both people
usually both refuse to stop being
selfish for even two seconds
that really is the truth I'm not saying
the truth every time but I think in the
majority of cases it is what kills a
marriage is consistent unrelenting
selfishness on the part of both people
I think that being being you know a good
spouse 99% of the time
consists of of very little things that
are that are really easy it consists of
taking the garbage out without grumbling
about it or or smiling at your spouse
when they come home from work asking
them how their day was it consists of
you know volunteering to be the one who
gets up in the middle of the night to
get a drink of water for the crying kid
that sort of stuff
I think if if in all of these really
small easy situations if we exercise a
little bit of patience a little bit of
selflessness our marriages will be fine
now there's still gonna be that 1%
there's gonna be that small minority of
really difficult challenging situations
those moments when doing the right thing
responding the right way might require
even something like heroism but the 99%
won't require anything close to them and
if you get into the habit of being
selfless in the 99%
then probably you'll react the right way
or close to the right way when the 1%
creeps up on
and I think that's the other thing
that
there might be plenty of marriages that
appear to have ended because of some
cataclysmic thing that occurred or some
great challenge that they bet that the
couple faced and it may seem on the
outside and may even seem to them that
this huge challenge is the thing that
that destroyed the marriage but I think
probably in most cases that's not true I
think what you'll find is that it was
kind of a that one or both of them had
been in the habit for a long time
leading up to that I've been in the
habit of selfishness and pettiness and
impatience and all of that and so there
had been this kind of cumulative effect
and then the big thing happens and it's
an explosion that blows them apart
because they have no stability they have
no strength at all in their in their
marriage and in the relationship and so
they don't have the foundations to
survive this big challenge and also they
themselves personally because they
haven't gotten into the habit of being
good you know being a good husband or
being a good wife when this huge
challenge arises they have no idea how
to approach that in the right way so I
think that's that's all that's needed to
be monogamous and faithful and and by
the way I don't I don't say any of this
as a person I've been married for going
on seven years so I'm hardly a marriage
expert compared to someone's been
married for thirty years I think I'm
still a novice and I also certainly have
not mastered the art of of doing what I
would call the easy thing you know and
and and being selfless and patient in
the small situations I have not at all I
have not I have not myself mastered than
99%
well that's part of the reason why I
know this
because so many times if I you know if I
am impatient or if I do the wrong thing
in one of these small situations you
know or there's a fight or something
like that I can look back on it later
and say what I mean why did I do that it
would have been so much easier to simply
do the you know it would have been so
much easier to have a little bit of
patience or to be a little bit selfless
so that's what I would say to the email
or don't don't be afraid of marriage
don't be afraid of it but but be be
discerning about who you Altima end up
with and and you do absolutely have to
go into it yourself completely ruling
out the possibility of divorce and
knowing that your future spouse has also
ruled out the possibility completely
ruled it out
and then at that point you you
charge out into the great unknown and
see what awaits you all right have a
great weekend everybody
Godspeed